ouah
je viens voir john gilling
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais une sorte de fou
dangereux créer un pont pan tilt et se
lance dans une forte relation origin
quel genre de folle dangereuse traverse
le pays d'est en ouest et se pointe
devant ma maison je te citer j'aimerais
que tu sois là avec mon père noël c'est
le genre de truc qu'on dit comme ça
genre votre bébé est trop mignon où je
commence le régime demain
tu veux dire que le cas existe qu'il est
à côté au wat tu devrais carrément
foncer je sais rien du tout de ce gars
moi je sais tout et donc je t'aimais de
séduire ok tag aime les femmes très
aventureuse il faut juste que tu te
détendre je me détourne l'attention
c'est la seule chose qui me mentir on
vire pas pourquoi est ce que tu fais ça
tu peux aussi me rendre un service saas
et c'est nathalie c'est l'infirmière de
grand mère nathalie est la petite amie
de ton frère
alors vous vous êtes siens
est-ce que tu as gardé ses anciennes
photos de profil une clé à molette une
hache et maintenant deux camps et le gaz
et l de n'avoir eu que trois matches
premiers mois que quand tout ça sera
terminé tu te feras un véritable profil
avec de vraies photos qui montrent le
vrai jo
je te promets
[Musique]